do you ever try to play a chest trap in
a game and it just never works out well
this video is for you today I found and
researched five different chest traps
that I think are going to happen in a
lot of games and looking at the main
database with a whole lot of games like
millions billions of games your opponent
will statistically fall for these traps
more than any
others so let's begin first with one
E4 there's a few traps um from here but
let's start with E5 okay um so in this
position Knight F3 is a very common
reply attacking that pawn and then black
defends it this is normal stuff we
develop the bishop black develops theirs
we play C3 we're trying to Target the
center black um brings their Knight out
they attack this Pawn on e4 but instead
of Defending it white can play this move
d4 and so far at this point there's
still like 4 million games in the
database a lot of lot of games have been
played to this point and black almost
always takes on D4 and plays Bishop B4
check and here we're going to block with
the
Knight so when we block with the Knight
we're actually walking into this pin and
inviting black to take this Pawn on e4
so black goes for it and then we get our
King out of the center so this is going
to be a Gambit we're going to sacrifice
not only our E4 Pawn but also our C3
Pawn because now black has up two
pawns but Black's King is in the center
we have a massive development advantage
and we're definitely going to be able to
punish this King in the center so in
this position we want to stop him from
being able to ever Castle so we play
Bishop to
A3 cutting that King off and then if
black Falls for this trap this is played
50% of the
time if black takes on A1 we have Rook
to E1
check and this King has nowhere to run
so after Knight E7 really the only way
to block we can just play Rook takes
E7 um and it's pretty much game over the
only way to stop Checkmate is to play
Queen takes E7 and just lose your queen
um so that's obviously going to be
winning for white so a very uh easy trap
for black to fall into black just takes
a few pawns and then all of a sudden
they lose so um that's a really good one
and then another one I wanted to show is
in the Vienna game so after after E4 E5
instead of Knight to F3 we try Knight to
C3 now black usually plays U more often
than not Knight to C6 Knight to F6 is
actually um an option but there's some
more traps and ideas there but the
really cool idea I wanted to show you is
after Bishop C4 Bishop C5 black just
keeps it simple tries to mirror us for
the time being we can play this crazy
move
Queen to G4 bringing your queen out like
this so early in the opening is really
bad you just don't want to do it um
because Black's going to be able to
attack that Queen and gain time so for
example black wants to move his D Pawn
up and Black's going to be able to do so
by winning time however if black did
move their dwn up say they went to D5 so
they're like aha I got you I double
attack your bishop and your queen
we're just going to take on G7 and we're
going to win that Rook on h8 um more
likely than
not so a rook is more powerful than a
bishop so we're happy to go into that so
often black sees this uh threat on G7
and plays Queen to F6 with the idea of
Defending and attacking and here this is
just such a a really cool move we can
play Knight to
D5 so we're just totally inviting black
to capture this Pawn on F2 and we just
slide our King over it's all good
staying chill and and everything's
fine
because we actually have a tremendous
amount of threats we're threatening
knight6 C7 threatening Queen six
G7 and in some lines we're threatening
Knight to
H3 and then the queen can kind of get
trapped in the center there's all sorts
of threats that black has to deal with
and we're only down a pawn gred our King
is in the center um but we're only down
a pawn so if we can get after this King
maybe uh get him to knock Castle maybe
win a rook like we're going to be in
really good shape so here black often
plays
D6 and now we have Queen takes G7 I
should have mentioned earlier
Queen to F1 would be Checkmate if this
bishop wasn't on C4 so we have to be
careful make sure this bishop is is
still seeing the square um but we're
good to play Queen 6 G7 here and this is
just really tough for black um we're
threatening again Knight takes
C7 Queen takes h8 so after Queen takes
G7 black is pretty much helpless they
can try to defend C7 play move like
Bishop B6 but this Rook is going to be
gone we actually don't really want to
take right now cuz if we do Bishop to G4
check would come and that's a little
Annoying we can still survive and we're
fine but it's uh not necessary to add
that counter playay we can just play
Knight to F3 and that Rook is still not
going anywhere um not to mention now
there's ideas of Knight takes B6 and
queen takes F2 or Bishop takes F2 or F7
anyway um this trap is really nasty so
you invite your opponent to take on F2
and then their position just falls apart
we're going to win material um one way
or another it's not going to lead to
Checkmate or anything but this is
decisive advantage and just right out of
the opening like six or seven Moves In
White is just completely winning it's
insane the next trap I wanted to show
you is in the Sicilian
Defense um and actually from the black
side so I'm going to flip the board here
and after Knight to F3 Knight to C6 D4
this is the open Sicilian we take on D4
Knight takes D4 Knight to F6 so we
attack that pawn on e4 and black defends
it with Knight to
C3 now um D6 is a the classical um
variation of the Sicilian um and after
this move the most
move from a club player level is Bishop
to E3 and after this move we have Knight
to G4 just being a pest and annoying
that bishop and it causes a lot of
problems because white really doesn't
want to give up the bishop pair and have
this really shattered and ugly Pawn
structure so instead of that they often
take on C6 and they go Bishop F4 I
should know if they go to D4 E5 is
really strong forcing the bishop back to
E3 and if Bishop F4 we can still play E5
where forcing it back to G3 now we can't
take that Bishop however we still have a
trick over sleeve we can play Queen to
B6 attacking
B2 and that's a pretty important Pawn if
we win B2 um feels like Black's position
starts to fall apart so white tries to
defend it with a rook to B1 and now we
play H5 so our plan is simple we want to
play H4 trap that Bishop on G3 and after
this move the most common played
move is
H3 which is a huge mistake black is now
completely winning because of this
really nasty idea we don't retreat we
don't hide in the face of danger instead
we play
H4
so you might be asking well isn't this
just a
trade and then isn't that a rook like
can he just win a rook but at the end of
all of that this crazy pattern with this
Pawn on G3 is enough to support F2
giving a Checkmate so a really nasty
combination where the pawn goes all the
way to G3 and supports that Queen just
really disgusting and any other bishop
move uh there's still Queen takes F2 cuz
the Knight is hitting that square so F2
is a really weak square and it can be
taken advantage of in this line so in
the kocon there's also another common
trap from the white side after this
which is the two Knights black often
takes and then plays Bishop F5 this is a
normal thing to do but this is actually
slightly bad already black should
probably play Knight to F6 here but
Bishop F5 is the most common move and
white plays Knight G3 kicks that Bishop
back and plays H4 so this is similar to
a different line in the
kocan except it's a little bit different
because
usually white has a Pawn on D4 and black
has say a knight on D7 something like
that and as we'll see the Knight coming
to E5 is a very dangerous idea for white
so after H4 black plays H6 we play
Knights E5 so we're attacking this
bishop if black lets us take it that's
going to be really really bad we just
take and this bishop can come to D3 on
this diagonal we could play H5 it's it's
really really ugly um and so
usually black Retreats this bishop
that's the only Square for the bishop to
go and then now we have this nice four
combination where we play Queen H5 we're
going to do a whole world tour with her
Queen right here so it goes over to the
king side and then G6 is played okay
let's go back here now we're threatening
F7 again okay so Black Blocks it all
right let's still threaten F7 for a
third move in a
row and after black plays Queen to D5
both stopping this threat and and
attacking the Knight on E5 we can play
the devastating Queen takes
B7 we saw this kind of idea where this
Rook is trapped in the Vienna
line but this has another twist to it
black can take this with check and then
just develop and say okay I'm I'm going
to get castle next turn and you know you
can take my Rook but my pieces are
pretty happy
but we don't have to take the Rook
instead we can play Queen C8 Checkmate
in one move that's crazy because in this
position Finly enough white more often
than not takes on a because they're just
so blinded by free rook that's the whole
idea of taking on B7 right well there's
also this idea which is important to
know um Queen C8 can be a really nasty
Checkmate the last one I wanted to show
you is against the Dutch defense um and
this is a weird move order but it's
really um really nasty so after Knight
F3 a lot of times people play The Dutch
against Knight F3 because it's um
slightly favorable to play it against
Knight F3 then D4 so anyway if people
will play F5 here you can play D3 three
a you know modest move we're not taking
too much space in the center and after
Knight F6 we just go for E4 we already
sacrificed this E4 pawn and ask black
what are you going to do we're
threatening to take potentially to play
E5 and so black obliges and takes this
Pawn now we bring this bishop to D3 with
with a Tempo we're attacking that Knight
but we also have nasty intentions of
going to this G6
Square so the Knight Retreats we play
Knight to G5 this is a weird looking
move but our idea is after a move like
Knight C6 we can play Knight takes
H7 and then Bishop to
G6 oh that is so gross that King is
just Ah that's terrible I mean we could
play Queen H5 too but I mean this is
this is
nasty um so anyway these are some of the
some of my favorite traps but I think
they are statistically some of the best
traps because your opponents are
actually pretty likely to fall for these
traps and um the most common moves often
lead to our opponent's demise so thank
you for watching and let us know in the
comments if you try this in your own
games